hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from round eight of the
individual European Championship that's
currently being played in in Skopje
Macedonia or Macedonia if you prefer
that way but it's an 11th round Swiss
tournament with a prize fund of 100,000
euros with I believe 20,000 euros goes
as first prize so here i've Ladislav
artemyev who is the top seed in this
tournament who who is really just been
playing phenomenal chess for the for the
past two years as far as I know really
taking even getting his ego rating
higher and higher I believe he's almost
at 2750 so that is you know in the top
elite and here he faces as being a
crotchet I checked the Grand Master who
in 1994 was the Czech chess champion and
sometimes in January in 1996 he was even
one of the top 20 players in the world
regarding feeder reigning so definitely
an interesting matchup and I'm sure
you're gonna enjoy the game as it's
really just just a a masterpiece but
you'll see what I mean
so without further ado let's just check
out this game our team it has the white
pieces and he opens with E for naughty
for sorry about that he opens with C for
the English opening we have c5 Knight to
f3 Knight to c6 and now we go into the
four Knights of the English we have III
East sixth and now with d4 and d5 we go
into well we transpose into the
symmetrical variation of the Terek
defense see capture son d5 by artemyev
he capture son d5 and now Bishop to b5
developing the bishop pinning the knight
fighting for the central squares and
here black besides the capture in the
center C capture son before we have a
capture son d4 and here those of you who
are who have been subscribed to my
channel for for some time now we already
had this position you know in a very
famous game I was played last year in a
in a blitz tournament in st. Louis
between momma Dee Arvin on and we're on
and went Bishop to d6 here and the momma
Dee off one a brilliant game I also did
a video on that game so if you're
interested in seeing it do check it out
it will be the the first
I think you'll see in the description
below is a link that will take it to
that game but in this game we have
Bishop to e7
bye-bye heretic and now comes castles by
both sides so they deviate from the mama
dr of on on the game and the Knight to
e5 just a nice standard idea getting
your knight into the center while black
of course is never a favor to capturing
then you get a nice pawn on e5 f4 is
coming and just everything works in
white's favor
so here black simply continues
developing we have Bishop to d7 and now
Bishop to g5 by white and rook the c8
developing the rook rook to e1 artemiev
develops his rook to e1 and now rook to
e8 and here we do have one game in the
database where a3 was played but here
artemiev goes for rook to see one and
move 13 and is it it's it's as of this
moment we have a completely new game so
this is where the players really now
start thinking and of course if you're
still in your preparation then you are
you know just enjoying the position but
okay we have a six asking what you want
to do with the bishop and here Artemyev
decides to give up the bishop pair we
have a bunch of characters the Bishop
captures and as the knight is no longer
pressuring the d4 pawn queen to f3
developing the Queen connecting rooks
and if you look at the position White's
pieces are a bit better
the knight is excellently placed on e5
and for the moment blacks LightSquared
Bishop is well we could say that it's
it's like a phone but doesn't really
matter now as long as you know black
keeps the Bishop repair and most likely
black will if white isn't interested in
giving up his monster night then well
it's a pretty equal position and here
it's about it's hard for for black to
find a plan first black develops the
Queen Queen to d6 a nice square for the
Queen also the rooks are now connected
and we have h3 by white rook to e3 is
possible immediately but artemiev
decides the well player played safely
for the moment we have brushable back to
d8 now opening up this efile for the
rook but the problem with the move
Bishop to d8 is that the rooks are no
longer connected and this is often when
you play
you know you're playing your own game
and you have this opportunity to do
something like this play let's say like
this always ask yourself is there is
there a way my opponent can take
advantage of my rooks not being
connected maybe maybe he can but maybe
he can and you will decide not to play
it about okay here are Tamia just goes
for a nice rock lift will look to III
preparing rooks Sita II one doubling
rooks on the e-file and here again it's
not all that easy to find a plan you
could go for something like h6 you could
offer something like b5 but in the game
rook to f8 was played tragic does not
like that this Knight and queen are
piling up on this f7 point so you cannot
move the knight black wants the defend
the s7 point now move the night
somewhere exchange the exchange the
bishops here and then try to play the
game from there so rook ct1 Artemyev
just doubles up on the e-file and here
black
okay black had a different plan but
since the roof is already on f8 perhaps
Knight to d7 was the plan and maybe
black just decided not to go for it
because here after let's say Knight
captures you could capture with the
b-pawn Bishop f4 attacks the Queen Queen
moves let's say to g6 now white could go
Knight 1/4 to take care of the c5 square
and here it's a playable position for
both white and black white is a little
bit better but nothing nothing out of
the ordinary you know but okay after
Luke CTE one rachac does not go for this
exchange immediately but rather he goes
Queen to b4 pressuring the BT pawn but
it's not it's not likely that you are
going to capture this pawn all of these
pieces are piling up around your king I
mean going point hunting at a in a
moment like this doesn't seem very
plausible but okay here comes the moment
we've mentioned Artemyev figures out
that the roofs are not connected the
rookin c8 is undefended first he
improves the position of the Queen Queen
to f5 now with an attack under broken c8
we have rook to e8 defending and now
comes Luke to d1 first you have to
defend before you can continue attacking
you do have to keep an eye on the d4
pawn and here the question is can the
pawn
unbe to be captured well here we have
our first puzzle of the game let's say
Queen captures and b2 was played how do
you proceed here
how does white continue this position
you can just pause the video for a
moment this is not the main puzzle of
the game this is just something that was
didn't even happen but yeah if you found
this congratulations if you just want to
just show rook the b1 simply it you're
not trapping the Queen the Queen's can
go to a3 but here's the problem Knight
captures c6 b captures and now you just
get Knight to e4 you open up a discovery
towards the Queen and whatever the Queen
does let's say go Queen captures on a 2
now you just capture with the check at
night captures Bishop captures and after
Bishop captures your upper piece black
does not have the option of recapturing
because if you recapture then just wrote
checks King goes here Queen captures on
f6 will be checkmate so for a moment it
is not possible to grab the b2 upon here
Rajic went for nights the I ate just
offering a trade of bishops and the not
allowing any future captures on f6 here
Artemyev went back bishop to f4 not
allowing this capture and his opponent
now goes back as now there's no danger
of capturing on f6 Knight back to f6
but now Artemyev just goes rook to g3
and now you can see that
well it's quite quite a dangerous
position here you could waste time with
something like g6 but white will not
have to react I mean you cannot capture
the Queen as the King is still on g8 so
here black decided to go King to h8 and
Artemyev just doubles up on the 3rd rank
which you know definitely something is
about to happen and here again you could
go for Queen captures on b2 but it leads
to the same line that happened in the
game after Bishop to eh this is what
black decided to play to keep an eye on
the f7 pawn and here artemiev just went
a3
he forces the Queen to capture we have
Queen captures on b2 and now you are
artemiev feel free to pause the video
and try to find you know the winning
idea for white here it's really really
just a wonderful plan and I know it
seems very simple when you think you saw
it
think again it requires you to think a
bit
a bit deeper so once again for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
summoner of your inner morphe and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
the idea is rook captures on g7 and for
this more for this opportunity I even
decided to put a nice morphe head here
on our team if I do I hope you don't
mind so I know you all found the rook
address on g7 that's pretty I mean
straight forward but what happens next
is is beautiful
King captures rook now comes look the g3
check I know you all saw this this is
not a problem
King to h8 but now comes the move you
had to see first
Knight captures on d5 this is just four
of you who saw even this far you're just
amazing and after Knight captures on d5
there's no better move Knight captures
here followed by Queen to h7 checkmate
is the threat so we do have to capture
it Knight captures displayed and the now
comes the move again yeah you had to see
in the position where we played rook
capture some g7 otherwise you you
weren't able to just sacrifice a rope I
mean you could wing it of course you
could but that's not how you play chess
over the board so once again for those
of you who made it all this far once
again pause the video here and continue
the attack for white there's only one
line that wins for white and it's really
a wonderful line once again for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you are just you know an
amazing player and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show Bishop to h6
the only move that wins because now well
if black does anything then comes Bishop
g7 check and Bishop moves to f6 opening
up a discovered checkmate from the rook
this is the threat white black has to
deal do something about this in the
position black played Bishop to f6 but
now once again very briefly pause the
video and try to find the the crushing
blow for white I'll give you a couple of
seconds as usual for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are I am I am you lost for words you're
just awesome and for those you who just
won injured so the move is of course
Queen captures on f6
and it was in this
that Czech Grand Master is being a
heretic resigned to the game unmoved 29
because there is nothing to do here that
is why he resigned
well it's check the only move you can
afford is Knight captures Queen and
would this move basically with Queen
captures Bishop you've removed the
defender of the g7 squared that's the
most important part
that's what Artemis did and after Knight
captures of course Bishop to g7 check
would follow King to g8 and now Bishop
captures on f6 is the checkmate that
we've discussed all along yeah a
wonderful game by artemiev who I will
now remove the morphe head by vladislav
Artemis in round 8 of the European
individual championship I even prepared
the final standings not the final but
the standings after round 8 there are 11
rounds so here it is which six and a
half points five people after eight
rounds that's a rotten Maxim kacper P
Aruna Vladislav Artemyev who is the top
seed in the tournament
Neels grand alias and andreas Banco
those of them with six and a half points
then a lot of players with six points
Martin Buser sheesh of Croatia also in
excellent 19th place could go could go a
long way if you know if a few more
victories are possible and even Boris
Gelfand there in 24th place with five
and a half points but still three more
rounds to go you know everything
everything can happen but so far artemiy
of the top seed definitely you know
living up to living up to his name and
the rating yeah yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it and that you were
able to solve not perhaps not all the
puzzles I've presented you with but at
least most of them or or if you didn't
solve them at least I hope you enjoyed
them India once again that's the game I
would like to thank Greg Crider and he
and his son Lincoln Troy
Karl Weinberg Joshua Thompson and ashish
kumar for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos we are thankful for watching and
i'll see you soon with some more
interesting content hopefully from this
champion from the US Championship
continue the Capablanca saga and so on
we do have a lot of things going on at
moment and I don't know I did some since
I do have a better graphics card now I
try to improve the quality of my camera
so I don't know if it's any any better
but if it is you know do do comments so
so I would know once again thank you all
and I will see you soon